[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public c'est
parti pour 90 minutes de débats et de
reportage et voici le sommaire de ce 18
juillet fallait-il interdire la
manifestation parisienne contre les
violences policières organisées samedi
le débat déchire la nupes mais pose
surtout une question de long terme quels
sont les effets de la mort de Naël et
des émeutes qui ont suivi dans l'opinion
qui va profiter la demande d'ordre et de
sécurité qui s'exprime chez une majorité
de Français on répond à ces questions
dans notre débat 100% politique où l'on
parlera aussi des rumeurs de remaniement
encore qui sont repartis de plus belles
ce lundi matin et puis pour notre second
débat on se projette dans un peu plus
d'un an le 26 juillet 2024 la cérémonie
d'ouverture des Jeux olympiques de Paris
la Seine comme décor un spectacle en
monovision un casse-tête d'organisation
et de sécurité aussi à la hauteur du
défi que représente ces jeux
au fond quelles sont nos défis être à
l'heure et dans l'excellence en termes
de réalisation
organisation sécurité
billetterie logistique transport
des rouler artistiques et sportifs etc
etc
où en sont les chantiers olympiques la
France sera-t-elle au rendez-vous des
infrastructures à la sécurité en passant
par les transports on fait le point tout
à l'heure sur ces jeux qui coûteront au
moins c'est encore provisoire 10
milliards d'euros mais d'abord
l'histoire d'une manifestation interdite
qui se déroule quand même Samia de chien
Le face à face était explosif d'un côté
le comité vérité et justice pour Adama
de l'autre labravenne brigade de
répression de l'action violente
motorisée la marche en mémoire d'Adama
Traoré mort en 2016 après son
interpellation par les gendarmes était
interdite elle s'est tenue quand même
d'abord pacifiquement jusqu'à ce qu'un
affrontement dégénère entre Youssouf le
frère d'Adama Traoré et les forces de
l'ordre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur ces images on le voit plaquer au sol
accusez d'avoir frappé un commissaire de
police il est interpellé puis
hospitalisé
par ici venez ceci cela ils sont venus
enfoncer sur moi ils ont chargés et
m'ont fait clé d'étranglement ils m'ont
fait l'occasion intra du monde la totale
pas non pris part à la marche dont des
élus écologistes et insoumis on a vu
arriver des motos de la braven dont je
redemande la dissolution de la manière
dont il se comporte ils sont utilisés et
qui ciblaient très clairement la famille
Adama la présence de parlementaires de
gauche à une manifestation interdite a
été vivement critiquée par la droite ce
week-end à l'image d'érections des
républicains la famille Traoré abrahavé
l'interdiction de manifester à Paris
accompagné par les factions et dangereux
députés de la nuque au cri insupportable
de tout le monde déteste la police ils
ont une fois de plus piétiner nos lois
et l'autorité de l'État insupportable
même reproche exprimée par la majorité
présidentielle la préfecture de police
de Paris allait interdit la marche en
raison de risques de troubles à l'ordre
public après cinq jours de violence
urbaines une décision validée par la
justice ce qu'on fait la loi on respecte
la loi on respecte la loi on respecte
les décisions de la justice et de
l'administration et on ne s'affiche pas
dans une manifestation interdite qui
plus est une manifestation interdite qui
a un réalité manifestation contre la
police une nouvelle marche contre les
violences policières et prévu le 15
juillet à Paris
je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités Chloé Ridel bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes porte-parole du Parti
socialiste Christelle craquelais bonsoir
et bienvenue directrice adjointe de BVA
opinion Emily appelle ski bonsoir
bienvenue à vous communiquante
fondatrice de l'agence Émilie conseil et
Mathieu croissanto il est politique
bonsoir Mathieu bonsoir bienvenue à vous
question toute simple que Ridel
faillit-il participer à cette
manifestation bah je pense que ce qui
est grave ça n'est pas que des députés
participent à tête manifestation
pacifiques ce qui est grave c'est que
cette manifestation ait été interdite
parce que précisément une semaine après
une série de violences très graves qui
ont lieu dans notre pays et que nous
condamnons tous là vous avez si vous
voulez une organisation une association
qui existe depuis un certain nombre
d'années qui portent des revendications
contre les violences policières et qui
le fait pacifiquement c'est un débouché
pour la colère qui s'est exprimée une
semaine plutôt et un débouché qui est
pacifique donc il ne faut absolument pas
étouffer ces initiatives donc moi je
pense que le gouvernement là commet une
erreur et donne raison à ceux nous
disent que le seul moyen de se faire
entendre c'est la violence on y
reviendra aux questions des violences
policières mais il y avait pas de
députés socialiste par exemple pourquoi
pourquoi ont-ils choisi pourquoi le
Parti socialiste est-il choisi de ne pas
y aller je suis pas sûr que le passé
socialiste se soit exprimé de façon
officielle sur sur fallait ou pas aller
à cette manifestation Olivier fort a
fait un tweet de soutien à
l'organisation et au comité qui
organisait la manifestation donc
mais quand une manifestation une
interdiction est validée par la justice
est-ce que les députés doivent aller
c'est il y a vraiment deux thèmes et on
prendra du temps sur la question de du
maintien de l'ordre en France de enfin
voilà des critiques exprimés mais est-ce
que c'est la place de député quand la
justice a dit non le recours a été
député par la justice et donc
effectivement ça pose ça pose une
difficulté mais moi je j'appelle quand
même élargir le débat sur cette question
et avoir qu'est-ce qu'on veut à la fin
dans ce pays je pense qu'il faut
absolument contenu le niveau de tension
et le niveau de violence qui s'est
exprimé il faut favoriser les non
violente et même si on n'est pas
d'accord avec les revendications que
porte le comité Adama en tant que
Monsieur Ciotti ne soit pas d'accord que
monsieur dussope ne soit pas d'accord il
faut permettre dans une démocratie au
désaccord de s'exprimer quand et de
façon non violente et c'est ce que fait
le comité pour Adama donc je il faut
absolument pas à mon avenir aussi des
violences verbales vis-à-vis des
policiers et on pouvait s'y attendre
dans un moment comme si jamais on y
reviendra sur le sur ces relations plus
que conflictuelles et les parts de
responsabilités Christelle Crapelet
peut-être j'ai décidé moi de commencer
sur la partie on va dire un peu plus
politique sur ce que ça révèle peut-être
de la de la nupette y a quoi il y a une
ligne de fracture qui s'exprime ou
est-ce que le terme est un peu fort face
à un événement comme celui-là alors on
n'a pas donné sur un élément comme
celui-là en revanche on a interrogé
récemment les Français pour leur
demander s'ils avaient jugé l'attitude
d'un certain nombre de parties adaptées
ou pas adaptées et ce qui est sûr c'est
que alors aucun parti ne ressort
vraiment grandi de la séquence mais
celui qui est le plus critiqué par une
majorité de Français c'est la France
insoumise dont l'attitude est jugée
inadaptée y compris en fait par une
majorité de sympathisants socialistes et
une partie importante de saint-astisant
ELV donc on sent qu'au sein des
sympathisants de partie qui composent la
nups ils ont pas tous la même perception
sur sur ce sujet-là
ça vous inspire quoi à la fois
l'organisation de cette manifestation et
son interdiction mais je pense que c'est
des sujets qui ont du mal à arriver sur
la table c'est quand même des sujets qui
se posent depuis un moment ce qui se
passe au sein de la police si on peut
parler on a l'impression que c'est un
tabou de parler d'éventuellement un peu
de racisme chez certains policiers je
mets beaucoup beaucoup de guillemets je
fais très attention on peut parler aussi
de violence qu'il se passe parfois dans
certaines manifestations et c'est vrai
que cette ces bravèmes c'est pas la
première fois qu'on en entend parler ce
qui dérange c'est que maintenant on a
des vidéos on a des sons qui prouvent
qu'il y a quand même parfois des
débordements et malheureusement c'est
des sujets qu'on n'arrive pas à faire
aborder par le gouvernement donc on
comprend que en tout cas c'est des
débats
est-ce organiser cette manifestation
dans ce climat là vous nous dites
c'était une manifestation pacifiste
est-ce que c'est le meilleur moment je
crois que c'est une manifestation ça
fait des années qu'elle se déroule de
manière très pacifiste tous tout se
passe bien et je pense que ça fait
monter la sauce de commencer à
l'interdire et c'est pas la première
fois encore une fois au-delà du tabou
sur ce qui se passe dans la police c'est
pas la première fois que le gouvernement
utilise ses interdictions souvient même
des interdictions pour les casseroles
qui étaient retoquées par la justice
donc il y a quand même une utilisation
la justice a suivi l'interdiction ça ne
fait que étouffer une colère qui qui
fait que bouillir il me semble moi je me
pose une question sur ce que je cherche
les élus insoumis ou les élus
écologistes enfin ceux de la nups qui
ont participé à quel moment ces gens-là
peuvent-ils se dire que défiler au cri
de tout le monde déteste la police c'est
une bonne chose ces gens-là veulent se
faire élire quand même et est-ce qu'ils
pensent qu'il y a une majorité
sociologique ou politique en France qui
pensent que tout le monde déteste la
police quand on regarde les sondages et
vous nous direz ce qu'indique nouveaux
indicateurs quand on regarde tous les
instituts on est plutôt entre 7 et 8
Français sur 10 qui ont plutôt confiance
à la police ça veut pas dire qui sont
pas critiques sur certaines actions
mais pas avec un slogan aussi débile et
excessif et insultant que tout le monde
déteste la police est-ce qu'on se fait
élire là-dessus je pense que c'est une
impasse politique deuxième chose si par
extraordinaire ils étaient élus est-ce
qu'ils pensent qu'on réforme une grande
institution une fonction publique en
commençant par insulter les gens est-ce
qu'ils pensent qu'on peut réformer
l'éducation nationale en disant tout le
monde déteste les professeurs non donc
si par extraordinaire ils étaient élus
ils auraient quand même bien du mal à
nouer ce dialogue avec les forces
syndicales avec les policiers avec un
slogan aussi excessif et débile je
continue donc je pense juste voilà je
pense que ils sont tellement dans
l'opposition Emmanuel Macron et c'est
tout à fait leur droit qui saute sur
tout ce qui bouge un peu tout ce qui est
tout ce qui est bon si tout c'est bon si
c'est contre Emmanuel Macron et je pense
que c'est une erreur tactique sinon
stratégique ouais le sondage auquel vous
faisiez allusion 75% des Français qui
c'était un sondage Opinion ouais qui
effectivement soutiennent la police
après toute la séquence que le que l'on
a vécu la semaine dernière Cloé delks je
crois pas du tout déjà une première
chose quand on est dans une
manifestation on ne maîtrise pas les
slogans qui sont scandés vous pouvez
trouver vous pouvez le trouver excessif
ce slogan mais en fait oui et il est
excessif mais en fait c'est un peu
dommage et c'est un peu court de vous
arrêter là parce que qu'est-ce qu'il
traduit ce slogan c'est à cela qu'il
faut s'intéresser il faut faire un peu
preuve d'empathie vous vous n'avez pas
un rapport avec la police qui est le
même que celui qu'on certains jeunes des
quartiers vous ne vous faites pas
molesté vous ne vous faites pas humilier
vous ne vous faites pas contrôler de
façon intempestive mais il y a un vécu
et une réalité de vécu de ces jeunes
vis-à-vis de la police il y a une
relation toxique entre la police et les
jeunes des quartiers qui s'est installés
depuis 40 ans et vous pouvez le nier et
dire à tout cela est excessif un moment
il faut entendre le message regardez on
a vu des images
mais
quel est l'intérêt quand on veut se
faire élire
le problème alors je vous dis des images
de la manifestation juste avant avec une
interpellation quand même hyper brutale
du frère d'Adama Traoré avec une jeune
femme aussi qui se fait pousser sur le
côté c'est ça la réalité de la police
donc quand ils disent tout le monde
déteste la police parce que en fait
toute la police évidemment
ni de violence qui peut avoir la police
de parler du fond du problème pour
justement finir avec cette spirale de la
violence je suis la première à le
vouloir comme vous cher Monsieur on se
on se contente de dire ah mais dis donc
c'est comme c'est excessif je vous ai
promis qu'on en parlerai de ce thème et
on va en parler mais la question de
Mathieu c'est une question sur la
stratégie politique de la nups face à
l'opinion française je pense c'est ce
que je disais en introduction
c'est-à-dire on est en soutien d'une
démarche Pacifique pour encourager ce
type de démarche et justement après une
semaine d'émeutes on montre que quand on
s'organise quand la société civile de
ces quartiers s'organise
et qu'elle s'organise de façon pacifique
pour faire valoir des revendications il
faut les soutenir c'est pas le meilleur
moyen de réformer ce slogan on est
d'accord là évidemment mais c'est pas
les élus ne scandent pas ça
je vais vous donner la parole tout de
suite
les politiques présents à la
manifestation n'ont jamais se demander
ce soir ils pouvaient solidariser alors
là c'est Gérard Darmanin qui le dit mais
bon ça apporte un élément à la
discussion le ministre de l'Intérieur
sur Twitter à la fin de cette journée de
de samedi donc voilà ce qui me tweet une
journée attendre en vain des regrets des
responsables de la nupes qui défilent
dans une manifestation interdite au cri
de tout le monde déteste la police
quelle tristesse pour la République pour
les femmes et les hommes qu'il a
défendent est-ce que effectivement il y
aurait dû avoir un message pour de la
part des députés qui étaient dans cette
manifestation pour se désolidariser de
ce slogan oui c'est possible et surtout
moi je questionne aussi comme Mathieu la
stratégie parce que on entend qu'un son
de cloche en fait on entend qu'une
direction depuis le début des émeutes
c'est à dire certains de la nups qui ne
critique pas ou ne dénonce pas la
violence qui a eu il y a eu même un
petit peu des appels sahela et la
violence et on est que dans ce sens là
c'est à dire qu'il y a pas d'autres
aspect du tout qui est investigué sur ce
qui se passe dans les banlieues ce qu'on
pourrait faire c'est vraiment toujours
sur cet angle c'est la police qui est
violente et qui est responsable et c'est
très limitatif donc participer à une
manifestation interdite avec ses slogans
et ne rien proposer à côté ça limite
quand même énormément
ça limite quand même l'action politique
même dans les paroles on a rien entendu
sur d'autres propositions on va entendre
vos propositions je vous propose
d'écouter
Eric Coquerel alors on est au lendemain
de cette manifestation le député elle
est fille évidemment de
Seine-Saint-Denis manifestation pour
faire libérer l'une des deux personnes
qui avaient été arrêté par la police
écoutons Eric Coquerel hier vous avez eu
une manifestation totalement Pacifique
donc tout le monde peut se louer y
compris la la volonté des organisateurs
de faire en sorte que ça soit ainsi
sauf qu'à la fin il y a la braven qui
intervenu on sait pas sous l'ordre de
qui pour arrêter très violemment deux
personnes et l'un des deux qui est le
frère de ASA Traoré qui est heureusement
ressorti mais dans un sale état
puisqu'il a été à l'hôpital et deuxième
manque du code du qui est ici dans le
commissaire du premier regard à vue
manifestement prolongée et dont on
demande sa libération alors que les
Ridel comme promis qu'est-ce que vous
proposez vous pour sortir de cette de
cette spirale effectivement interminable
qui dure je suis assez d'accord avec
vous depuis quasiment 40 ans absolument
alors je vais parler pour le Parti
socialiste en l'occurrence le Parti
socialiste ça fait carrément une
conférence de presse si vous voulez la
semaine dernière pour présenter toutes
les propositions que nous faisons pour
justement s'attaquer aux causes
profondes de cette spirale de la
violence il y a évidemment un volet de
réforme de la police de réévaluation de
cette fameuse loi de février 2017 sur
qui encadent donc
le
des policiers absolument mais
qui demande sa révolution voilà
il y a aussi il y a aussi la
reconnaissance du fait de racine du
racisme dans la police on veut qu'il y
ait une étude qui soit clairement faite
là-dessus on veut qu'il y ait aussi un
contrôle indépendant de la police donc
que l'IGPN ne soit plus sous le contrôle
du ministère de l'Intérieur puis il y a
un volet aussi d'éducation dans cette
réponse à ces violences urbaines il y a
un problème de mixité sociale dans ce
pays de ghettoïsation urbaine sociale et
donc scolaire donc il faut briser les
phénomènes notamment de ghettoïsation
scolaire recréer de la mixité dans les
collèges dans les lycées puis un volet
aussi sur cette problème de mixité sur
le logement social il y a des tas de
communion de France qui ne respectent
pas le taux de logements est-ce que ça
excuse les violences
une position très claire sur ce sujet
aucune violence n'est justifiable et
nous les avons rejetés tout de suite et
nous nous sommes démarqués effectivement
sur ce point donc nous nous sommes très
clairs et je crois que la violence non
seulement est moralement condamnable
mais qu'elle est aussi
inefficace sur le plan politique parce
que vous le disiez très justement
c'était vous madame il y a effectivement
des divergences de vue au sein de la
gauche il y en a qui disent la violence
est efficace et d'autres dont je suis
qui disent que non la violence n'est pas
efficace en tout cas elle est moins
efficace que la non-violence et là on
l'a vu en une semaine qu'est-ce qu'a
produit la violence elle a divisé le
front de soutien les Français sont
radicalement opposés à ces violences
elle a justifié une dérive sécuritaire
je veux dire dans les propositions du
gouvernement et puis de toute la droite
et de l'extrême droite surenchères il
faut retirer les aides sociales aux
familles il faut bloquer les réseaux
sociaux donc c'est ça le résultat de la
viande et à la fin l'extrême droite
visiblement selon les sondages qui
augmentent
c'est encore un peu tôt on essaye de de
commencer à mesurer on va dire les
effets à long terme de de ce qui s'est
passé c'est dix derniers jours ces deux
dernières semaines comment vous vous le
vous le percevez ça il y a deux choses
il y a d'abord la séquence à provoquer
beaucoup d'inquiét udes chez les
Français
et par une demande de
faire une demande
de mesure et celle qui sont très dures
par exemple ne plus tenir compte de
l'excuse de minorité pour pour des
mineurs délinquants suscite une addition
très très forte à plus de 80%. alors que
les mesures plus sociales favoriser la
mixité mener une politique ambitieuse
pour les quartiers suscite aussi une
adhésion majoritaire mais beaucoup plus
en retrait autour de 56 60%
allez au bout de la démonstration je
vous poserai une autre question
une inquiétude sur cette situation une
compréhension sans doute des problèmes
qui peuvent s'exprimer dans les
quartiers mais elles se traduit quand
même davantage par une demande de
fermeté que que de social alors est-ce
que ça s'explique parce que on est
encore à chaud ou est-ce que c'est
d'après vous une tendance de fond c'est
un peu tôt pour pour le dire c'est vrai
que nous dans nos enquêtes de pignons on
voit quand même des des juments parfois
un peu durs de la population française
et c'est vrai que face aux réactions
politiques comme je disais tout à
l'heure les jugements sont très
critiques pour tous les partis en
revanche celui qui s'en sort le moins
mal on va dire c'est le rassemblement
national c'est lui par exemple dans la
question que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
qui est considérée comme ayant eu
l'attitude la plus adaptée avec autant
de personnes qui jugent ça adaptées que
pas adapté alors que tous les autres
partis ont une majorité de perception
négatives donc ça et ça c'est pas la
première fois là dans la séquence
retraite c'était exactement la même
chose on voyait un rassemblement
national qui entre guillemets tirait un
peu plus profit de la situation même si
voilà lui aussi est critiqué comme tous
les autres partis et et le piège qui est
tendu parce que cette demande de fermeté
il va y avoir forcément une réponse de
fermeté et ne doit pas nous exonérer de
cette réflexion sur l'action des forces
de police parce que contrairement à ce
que vous pensez ce que vous me reprochez
de penser je considère qu'il y a un
problème dans la police dans le rapport
à cette population là non je considère
qu'il y a un problème oui c'est bien il
y a pas à dire c'est bien c'est pas bien
je le conseiller en tout cas qui a un
problème c'est reconnu qu'il y a des
attitudes des forces de police dans les
quartiers populaires qui ne sont pas
acceptables le tutoiement les les gestes
physiques le harcèlement de contrôle
d'identité de gens qui le connaissent
par cœur tout cela crée des situations
de tension qui ne favorisent pas
évidemment le dialogue surtout quand une
pause lisse et projetée dans des
quartiers elle n'y est pas installé
puisqu'on a supprimé il y a quelques
années déjà la police de proximité qui
était une initiative du gouvernement
Jospin après ce que je dis c'est que on
ne peut pas répondre à cette demande de
fermeté en s'exonérant de ce chantier là
qui va être colossal qu'on a jamais
abordé ni la droite ni la gauche la
gauche la fait un peu sous-joint j'ai
dit avec cette police de proximité on le
reprochait à l'époque assez va essayer
de jouer au foot avec les Nicolas
mais depuis ce temps-là on n'a pas
réfléchi là-dessus et je pense qu'on ne
peut pas résumer cette réflexion un
slogan c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure ce que tout le monde déteste la
police me paraît débile c'est aborder
les choses comme ça c'est ce qu'on
entend dans c'est ce qu'on entend dans
ces manifestations
qui déclare ça je pense que c'est c'est
c'est très mal abordé c'est très mal
abordé le débat
cette jeunesse là et pardon mais les
légitimes de ces populations là il y a
un moment il faut être avec eux à leur
côté et manifester et oui s'il y a des
slogans qui sont vous savez pas dire que
vous les reprenez à votre compte et je
pense que c'est pour ça
je vais vous donner la parole mais l'un
qui ne réagit pas par exemple au
communiquer alliance et qui ensuite vont
donner des leçons
les mots ont un sens ont du poids la
responsabilité des politiques il se
trouve que il se trouve que la semaine
dernière il y a deux policiers qui ont
été tabassés en rentrant chez eux dans
l'Essonne et dans les Yvelines dans
l'Essonne il y avait sa petite fille qui
était dans la voiture évidemment que
c'est inacceptable on est on est quand
même dans un pays où les policiers se
remettent en civile avant de rentrer
chez eux mais voilà de portes d'être de
peur d'être ici première victime de
cette voilà c'est aussi il faut pas non
plus avoir une vision caricaturale ou
angélique de la situation est policier
dans ces quartiers c'est très compliqué
aussi ça n'excuse pas le tutoiement ça
n'excuse pas le délit facile etc mais
c'est aussi la réalité du pays
aujourd'hui et je pense que il y a une
erreur stratégique encore une fois de la
nuit pèse globalement de communiquer
beaucoup sur ça sur les violences
policières de participer justement à
cette manifestation interdite et de ne
pas être du tout sur la valeur
d'autorité et d'ordre parce que
globalement et on le voit bien avec la
montée du RN la société française est en
demande de d'ordre d'autorité et on le
voit d'autant plus quand il y a des
émeutes et là-dessus la gauche est
complètement noyée par ce combat contre
les violences policières et sa noix
complètement le poisson et il faut que
la gauche se réveille parce que c'est
l'extrême droite qui en profite
énormément si elle n'a pas de discours
sur l'autorité elle perd complètement
pied par rapport à la société nous nous
pensons qu'il n'y a pas d'ordre durable
sans justice et nous sommes nous
espérons en ordre qui soit républicain
mais en face côté gouvernement et côté
droite on a l'aspiration à un ordre
profondément et descendants nous je
pense que nous avons une position plus
équilibrée que vous que vous ne le dites
ou nous condamnons très fermement les
violences où nous disons que parmi les
victimes de cette politique de maintien
de l'ordre inepte qui est dénoncé par de
multiples organisations internationales
les victimes en sont aussi les policiers
alors que on ne va pas attaquer nos
mémément des policiers de façon
individuelle on s'attaque à
l'institution quand on parle de
violences policières il y a quelque
chose qui ne fonctionne pas dans
l'institution c'est à dire qu'on
n'arrive pas dans l'institution policier
en étant violent on le devient et donc
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on le devient donc
nous essayons d'avoir un discours
équilibré mais si nous alertons sur la
question de violence policière c'est que
nous sommes les seules forces à le faire
en face vous avez un déni total je vous
rappelle que Gérald Darmanin disait
encore il y a un an violence policière
je m'étrangle je ne sais pas ce que ça
veut dire ça n'existe pas
de racisme mais dans la police ben vous
voyez il y a en fait en face une espèce
de déni totale qui effectivement est
quand même
alors même que des organisations
internationales le soulignent donc je
pense qu'on a consacré pas mal de temps
à cette question mais dans les parmi les
conséquences des violences
urbaines de la semaine dernière il y a
aussi un texte et j'appelle Jonathan du
priez à nous rejoindre tout de suite sur
le plateau bonsoir Jonathan bienvenue à
vous un texte qui doit être adopté avant
la fin de la session parlementaire oui
ça va pas être de tout repos Emmanuel
Macron ici engagé devant les maires
qu'il a reçu mardi dernier à l'Elysée il
va il veut faire adopter une loi
d'urgence dans le contexte post et meute
vous venez de le dire Thomas ce texte et
ben à quoi il sert il doit permettre de
reconstruire les édifices publics la
voirie les écoles qui ont été dégradées
pendant ces violences urbaines qui ont
suivi la mort du jeune Naël et
reconstruire le plus rapidement possible
et c'est en tout cas l'esprit de ce
projet de loi je cite le chef de l'État
il veut écraser tous les délais induits
par cette reconstruction et aussi
débloquer une enveloppe financière
destinée à ces communes les plus
touchées et l'idée aussi c'est de
tourner la page de cette séquence comme
le résumé le chef de l'État il y a
quelques jours en marge du Tour de
France écouter le
nous avons tous vécu un moment important
dans la vie de la nation donc on va
continuer de travailler d'abord la
première réponse c'est l'ordre le calme
c'est la Concorde et ensuite c'est de
travailler sur les causes profondes de
ce qui est devenu merci alors que
sait-on précisément du texte à ce stade
alors on est allé un peu la pêche aux
infos aujourd'hui on a encore il y a
encore beaucoup de fous mais ce qu'on
sait c'est à ce stade c'est un texte
très technique qui comporte quatre
articles seulement et c'est le ministère
de la transition écologique la cohésion
des territoires qui sera saisie au fond
donc Christophe Béchu et de la vœu d'un
conseiller gouvernemental c'est une loi
d'habilitation je cite un peu vide qui
devrait permettre à l'exécutif de
légiférer par ordonnance alors qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire légiférer par
ordonnance et bien conformément à
l'article 38 de notre Constitution le
Gouvernement peut demander au Parlement
son accord pour finalement se passer de
lui en quelque sorte et prendre par
ordonnance des mesures qui relèvent
normalement du domaine de la loi alors
vous doutez bien que ici au Sénat on
n'est pas très friand de ce dispositif
de légiférer à part ordonnance parce que
finalement c'est ça revient à se
dessaisir de son pouvoir du Parlement
mais au vu de circonstances
exceptionnelle et c'était le cas
notamment pendant le covid il y a eu une
cinquantaine d'ordonnances qui avait été
prise et bien parfois ça permet d'aller
plus vite
et au niveau du calendrier Thomas
c'est la fin de saison j'étais en train
de réfléchir à la suite alors ça donne
quoi au niveau du calendrier là encore
les sources gouvernementales elle nous
indique la date du 13 juillet c'est ce
jeudi pour la présentation du projet de
loi en conseil des ministres c'est le
Sénat qui aura la primeur du texte spa
étonnant vu qu'il concerne les
collectivités quant aux dates d'examens
du texte à proprement dit pour la
chambre haute ce sera donc les 17 et 18
juillet a priori j'espère que vous avez
votre carnet de notes l'Assemblée
nationale prendra le relais le 19 en
commission et le 20 juillet en séance
publique et dans le cas où les deux
chambres ne se mettraient pas d'accord
sur un texte identique et bien il y a
déjà une commission mixte paritaire qui
est prévue pour le 21 juillet qui est le
jour officiel de la fin de session
extraordinaire et les débats pourraient
même se prolonger peut-être le week-end
éventuellement mais ça à ce stade
évidemment on ne le sait pas encore en
tout cas le gouvernement aimerait tout
boucler avant la semaine du 24 juillet
merci beaucoup je l'attends désolé pour
cette relance oubliée quel bilan je sors
chlory d'elle de d'uniquement la
question de voilà des forces de police
de de des solutions parce que ce des
solutions tellement complexes que
personne n'a trouvé depuis 4 décennies
sur le court terme quel bilan fait de
l'action du gouvernement depuis la mort
de Naël
je trouve qu'il est très inquiétant
pourquoi parce que la réponse est
exclusivement sécuritaire mais qu'est-ce
qu'on pourrait faire autre chose quand
il y avait quand il y a eu cinq nuits
d'émeutes
de jambes parce que encore une fois il
n'y a pas d'ordre durable sans justice
et nous aspirons tous je crois que
l'urgence est à la paix la
réconciliation je pense qu'on est tous
d'accord pour dire ça mais pour parvenir
à cette pacification durable il faut
regarder les racines profondes comme
disait le président de son propos sauf
que comme d'habitude il dit quelque
chose mais les actes tardent à suivre
moi ce que je constate c'est que 10
jours après la mort tragique de Naël si
vous voulez on est passé de de la mise
en examen d'un policier pour homicide
volontaire au procès des banlieues et on
parle on a parlé de blocages sociaux de
criminalisation des parents d'autorité
parentale etc et à aucun moment on a
parlé de la question par exemple pas du
25 % de logements social est-ce que on
oblige enfin les mers à respecter la loi
est-ce que s'il ne respecte pas la loi
l'État s'est substituera j'ai noté que
le gouvernement d'Édouard Philippe
s'était en 2017 avait justement assoupli
et permis aux maires de ne pas atteindre
cet objectif de 25% de logements social
et c'est le maire de Trappes qui prenait
cet exemple il dit bah voilà moi à
trappe j'ai 60% de logements social et
une autre commune des Yvelines s'appelle
Maisons-Laffitte elle en a 10% et donc
si vous voulez ça c'est très
problématique parce que le problème
c'est derrière tout cela derrière toutes
ces violences c'est quand même un
phénomène de ghettoïsation qu'il faut
absolument briser donc moi je trouve que
la réponse n'est pas à la hauteur et
qu'elle risque d'amplifier la spirale de
la violence
avec aussi la question de l'école l'é
c'est très bien que les écoles dans ces
zones sont surchargées que ce sont des
jeunes professeurs qui sont envoyés
alors qu'il faudrait plutôt avoir des
professeurs expérimentés bref et là
aussi oui
par deux
pour les pour les tout jeunes enfants
moi ça me fait penser vraiment au
service au service des urgences de
l'hôpital on a fait internet des
diagnostics pour ne pas avancer et là
quand même on a un Emmanuel Macron qui
nous dit il va falloir prendre le temps
pour faire le diagnostic et pour savoir
ce qu'on va faire on avait quand même et
on n'arrête pas de le rabâcher depuis
deux semaines un plan Borlo qui avait
été commandé par Emmanuel Macron qui a
été jeté à la poubelle par Emmanuel
Macron on a des maires encore récemment
là au Congrès des villes qui ont
ressorti un des mesures du plan Borlo en
disant au gouvernement banco on y va on
y va sur la rénovation des logements on
y va sur l'éducation on y va sur la
police on a l'impression qu'on piétine
et tout à l'heure vous disiez la
violence bah si la violence elle a
permis qu'on en reparle mais sauf que le
gouvernement n'est pas encore à la
hauteur de ses problèmes là je suis
d'accord que la question sécuritaire
était indispensable parce que c'est une
demande de la société et puis c'est
évident on va pas laisser s'enflammer
les banlieues mais en parallèle est-ce
qu'on peut pas avoir en même temps qu'il
soit intelligent c'est à dire de traiter
l'urgence et en même temps de commencer
à dresser les lignes d'un diagnostic
encore une fois on connaît déjà beaucoup
et de commencer à poser les jalons et de
pas attendre encore dans 5 ans ou dans
10 ans qui a une nouvelle de nouvelle
émeutes pour je ne sais quel cas je
n'espère pas de mort ou de d'accident
dramatique comme il s'est passé un mot
sur peut-être Gérald Darmanin est-ce
qu'il tire profit de de la quinzaine qui
vient de se passer ou pas relativement
aussi en fait on a posé la même question
sur les parties aux membres de
l'exécutif globalement ils sont
critiqués Gérald dahmanon aussi mais
c'est celui qui s'en sort entre
guillemets le moins mal qui a le plus de
jugements positif versus le jugement
négatif ça cote d'influence c'est à dire
le souhait qu'on qu'il exerce un peu de
un rôle à l'avenir progresse aussi alors
il reste assez clivant il est beaucoup
plus clivant qu'une qu'une personnalité
même dans le gouvernement comme comme
pour le maire mais il sort de la
séquence enfin il en tire plutôt
profitation il a été beaucoup plus
humble et moins agressif que d'habitude
en essayant de tenir un équilibre entre
la sécurité et puis ce qui se passait
sur les prénoms des métiers des choses
comme ça je trouvais qu'il a eu un
équilibre qui enfin que je lui ai
reconnaissait pas auparavant peut-être
parce qu'il espère être Premier ministre
et évidemment on parlera du remaniement
dans un instant mais dans ce contexte de
tension de violence on se posait la
question de la responsabilité des prises
de parole publique je vous propose de
regarder
ce dérapage moi c'est le terme que je
j'emploie de la chanteuse easyaste et
lors d'un concert du festival des Nuits
guitares c'est jeudi soir à
Beaulieu-sur-Mer regardez je pense que
ce que le peuple veut ce dont le peuple
a envie c'est qu'on accroche à 20 mètres
du sol telle une pinata humaine géante
[Applaudissements]
et qu'on soit tous
me battent avec des clous au bout comme
dans Glock orange tu vois
et là on le ferait descendre mais avec
toute la grâce et la gentillesse que les
gens du Sud ont
là juste au dessus de vous et on aurait
tous notre pâte avec nos petits
et dans un feu de Bengal de joie de
servir et de sang
[Musique]
on le foutrait à terme et gentiment
de la République conséquence directe ce
lundi la mairie de Marcq-en-Baroeul dans
le Nord a décidé d'annuler le prochain
concert de jeudi
mère LR les républicains de
Marcq-en-Baroeul est-ce que vous
comprenez la décision de ce maire où
est-ce que vous dites c'est une sorte de
liberté d'expression d'une artiste
finalement
je me pose à toutes les appels à la
violence contre contre des personnes
enfin c'est voilà c'est vraiment pas mes
valeurs mais je crois que l'artiste
s'est excusé dans un communiqué donc il
y a tout permis de penser qu'elle ne
reproduira pas de tels propos donc
pourquoi annuler
un concert je trouve ça dommage
excessif
c'est de la provocation
si ça avait été n'importe quel autre
personnalité politique qui avait subi ce
type d'attaque je pense que tout le
monde aurait été saisi parce que la
scène est quand même décrite avec force
détails on est sur l'expression moi ça
me frappe la violence qui peut régner
dans dans 15 pire ce pouvoir dans les
milieux culturels et je dis on l'avait
vu au moment du festival de Cannes avec
le le discours de Justin truie qui lui
avait une portée politique c'est
laquelle dénonçait la marchandisation de
la culture d'accord pas d'accord
l'exception culture l'exception
culturelle qui serait cassée par ce
pouvoir
là on n'est pas dans un propos qui a une
portée politique on est dans du chaud du
buzz de la provocation
est-ce qu'il y a un détestation
d'Emmanuel Macron plus forte que celle
qu'on peut vivre d'autres présidents de
la République parce que c'est un peu le
lot du du chef de l'État et une
détestation très très forte et qui
progresse en fait depuis ces dernières
années nous on pose des questions
ouvertes c'est à dire qu'on laisse les
gens s'exprimer pourquoi et vous n'aimez
pas manuels Macron et il y a parfois des
propos extrêmement violents à son égard
donc il y a une détestation très très
forte qui s'expriment en termes très
virulent à son égard après ça ça ne date
pas non plus que d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
déjà depuis une dizaine d'années où il y
a un rapport aux hommes politiques aux
hommes aux femmes politiques de plus en
plus critiques chez les Français Émilie
mais plus globalement dans la société
parce qu'on a l'impression moi je me
pose la question de l'autorité c'est
quoi on a le droit de faire quoi quand
on est responsable politique quand on
est artiste moi je suis très choqué
parce qu'il se passe mais je suis très
choqué aussi qui est au gouvernement des
gens qui sont en examen ou des gens qui
jouent avec la mémoire de Samuel aussi
pour faire on ne sait pas quoi en fait
il y a un mélange de genre des deux
côtés et je comprends que il y a
beaucoup de mépris je pense d'un côté et
de l'autre parce qu'on a l'impression
que tout est possible et qui a plus de
grade de morale quelque part de morale
publique civils sociales et que on peut
dire ce qu'on veut qu'on soit
responsable politique qu'on manifeste
dans les méfélations interdites avec
l'écharpe de la France je trouve qu'il y
a un mélange et peut-être que ce
gouvernement exacerbe ça parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de cas et c'est vrai qu'on
avait un Emmanuel Macron qui était tout
pur en 2017 en annonçant que ça serait
le quinquennat de la grande morale et
qui aurait pas de mise en examen je dis
pas du tout que ça ça pardonne ce qui a
fait cet artiste là Izia mais on a
l'impression que tout est possible de
tous les côtés c'est une espèce
d'escalade il y a plus il y a plus de
morale on dirait allez on ouvre un
dernier chapitre dans ce débat 100%
politique l'interview de la première
ministre c'était ce dimanche dans le
Parisien Aujourd'hui en France Mathieu
est-ce que c'est le signe qu'elle va
rester à Matignon qu'elle aimerait bien
elle est assez curieuse d'ailleurs cette
interview parce que tous ceux qui
attendaient la première ministre qui est
livré une forme de grise de lecture
politique j'allais dire sociologique des
événements qui se sont passés dans ce
pays et c'est pas rien quand même les 5
jours d'émeutes qu'on a qu'on a subi
tout cela en ont été pour leur frais
parce qu'on n'est pas dans le registre
analytique mais plutôt dans le registre
comptable avec son lot de chiffres à la
clé j'ai un tableau sous les yeux et je
constate que la plupart des chantiers
sont au vert sur la Premier ministre
nous avons délivré le terme n'est pas
neutres non plus pour le commun des
Français comme le dit de Larousse
délivrée s'est débarrasser quelqu'un de
ce qui entrave cette liberté mais pour
la prisonnière volontaire de Matignon
délivrer 100 ans dans son exception
anglo-saxonne c'est-à-dire cette espèce
de novlangue insupportable de
managériale délivré c'est faire aboutir
un projet en l'occurrence elle parle de
la fameuse feuille de route des 100
jours que l'ufxc Emmanuel Macron puis
alors on était aussi resté sur sur notre
fin en termes de confidences sur ces
états d'âme ou sur ses discussions avec
le prénom la République parce que c'est
la règle du jeu mais là c'est l'angle de
bois les moins de langage et verrou à
tous les étages je ne suis pas dans le
commentaire mais dans l'action dire je
ne commande pas les rumeurs je ne ferai
pas de commentaires sur la ministre tout
juste s'autorise-t-elle à rappeler
qu'Emmanuel Macron avait eu l'occasion
de dire qu'elle avait sa confiance et
tout juste autorisé à la mettre en garde
les prétendants le poste de première
ministre a toujours ressuscité beaucoup
d'intérêt chacun chacune ne réalise
chacun pardon ne réalise peut-être pas
complètement la réalité et la difficulté
de la fonction est-ce que ça veut dire
que le remaniement n'est pas pour tout
de suite mais bien malin qui le sait à
part le président puisque de toute façon
on sait qu'il y a que lui qui décide de
tout la seule chose c'est que plus le
temps passe plus l'hypothèse d'un
remaniement d'ampleur paraît compromise
parce que à quoi bon en effet t'envoyer
tenter d'envoyer un signal fort aux
français quand ceci on le nez sur leur
serviette de plage alors certains
ministres ont dû soucis à se faire on le
sait mais un remaniement technique
suffirait pour les délivrer cette
fois-ci au sens propre du terme merci
Mathieu Criel est-ce que les Français
attendent quoi que ce soit d'un
remaniement attendre même je pourrais
même simplifier la question attends d'un
remaniement non je pense qu'on peut
vraiment pas dire ça si on leur pose la
question évidemment ils vont vous dire
oui puisqu'en fait il y a une majorité
de Français qui sont contre ce
gouvernement mais derrière il y a pas
autant de force d'un remaniement qui
viendrait tout d'un coup faire qui
change d'avis de toute manière la
personne principale contre qu'ils en ont
c'est Emmanuel Macron la popularité des
îles Elizabeth borne en fait elle suit
de très près la côte de popularité de
d'Emmanuel Macron et il y a pas une
attente très très forte qu'elle change
qu'elle soit remplacée et surtout par
qui aussi parce qu'on l'a dit tout à
l'heure l'image des personnalités
politiques et quand même très négative
dans l'opinion on en attend pas grand
chose mais ça a des conséquences quand
même sur le l'activité ou l'inactivité
de certains ministres moi j'ai
l'impression que ça se sclérose la
plupart des ministres en fait qui ne
savent pas s'ils peuvent parler avant
que le grand chef ne parle ou une
annonce parce qu'on a un Emmanuel Macron
qui continue à être omniprésent sur à
peu près tous les sujets donc c'est
comme s'il devait me demander
l'autorisation même dans leur
portefeuille de pouvoir dire un petit
peu des annonces et puis évidemment les
uns et les autres se demandent s'ils
vont rester ou s'ils peuvent partir
parce qu'il y en a je pense qu'ils
veulent partir aussi et puis surtout ça
n'imprime pas il y a aucun sujet qui
imprime alors les émeutes et ils sont
pour quelque chose c'est terrible pour
Emmanuel Macron puisque à la fin de ces
100 jours on arrive sur de ses émeutes
qui enlèvent tout qui brosse tout qui
efface tout ce qu'il a pu faire et tout
est au point mort quelque part même si
elle a délivré rendu France travail
qu'est-ce qu'il y a les lycées
professionnels elle parlait un petit peu
immigration on voit que ça patauge
complètement les Français n'attendent
pas le remaniement mais ils voient bien
qu'il y a rien de clair qui se dessine
ni pour cet été ni pour la rentrée alors
peut-être qu'ils sont blasés qu'ils ont
surtout envie de partir en vacances et
d'oublier tout ça mais ça laisse
présager un automne qui va être à mon
avis assez compliqué à gérer
politiquement donc pluriel c'est un peu
ridicule c'est rumeurs récurrent des
remaniements moi j'ai l'impression que
d'être dans un jeu de surface
non c'est vrai que c'est c'est pas loin
de ce que je ressens je beaucoup de fois
pour pas grand chose finalement parce
que à quoi servir et ce remaniement
est-ce que derrière il y a un changement
de politique ou pas est-ce que il y a
une alliance avec les LR enfin bon là on
a juste l'impression de quelqu'un à
présent de la République qui joue avec
les nerfs de Premier ministre et qu'il
les pousse à
prendre la parole de façon un peu débile
dans l'espoir de se faire remarquer mais
enfin c'était un c'est un spectacle un
peu ridicule moi je pense que la
première chose et la première des sens
compte tenu des résultats de la
commission d'enquête parlementaire du
Sénat la semaine dernière ce serait
d'abord de faire en sorte que Madame
Schiappa démissionne ce serait de
condamner publiquement cette ministre ça
me paraît beaucoup plus urgent et
important que les rumeurs autour d'un
remaniement c'est quand même très grave
cette affaire il y a eu aucun
commentaire qui a été fait sur ce
plateau
c'est intéressant ce que vous dites
parce que effectivement il y a deux
options il y a l'option d'attendre un
remaniement et donc à ce moment-là
c'est pas vraiment médiatisé quoi c'est
un remaniement et Marlène Schiappa n'est
pas dans le nouveau gouvernement ou
alors il y a le fait de marquer le coup
par une diminution en fait on déplore
quand même le manque de confiance des
Français dans la politique là on a une
ministre qui de façon totalement
irresponsable en rejetant d'ailleurs la
responsabilité qui devrait être la
sienne sur ses collaborateurs utilisent
l'argent public fait mobiliser en la
mémoire d'un professeur tué et décapité
par un terroriste islamiste de façon
extrêmement légère à l'utilise cet
argent public sans aucun résultat etc
la moindre des choses rappelez-vous ce
qui avait fait Hollande face au scandale
de Jérôme Cahuzac bon bah il avait il
avait pu reconnaître il avait pu un
soutien qui avait duré sans doute un peu
trop longtemps à l'époque j'avais autour
de 20 ans donc
en tout cas il y avait eu une réaction
politique là on l'attend toujours et ça
me paraît bien plus urgent que des
rumeurs sur un hypothétique remaniement
ce qui est intéressant c'est on essaie
d'en se débattre sortir un peu de voilà
de d'avoir pas trop le nez le nez dans
le guidon et de prendre un petit peu de
de recul et là je voudrais vous entendre
sur le lien entre les Français et la
République de manière générale c'est la
confiance qui peuvent avoir dans leurs
élus dans la République une affaire
comme celle-là effectivement
et la mise en cause de marine Chapat
quel impact ça peut avoir dans l'opinion
ça peut avoir qu'un impact négatif déjà
leur confiance dans les institutions
elle est extrêmement limitée alors il y
a quelques institutions qui s'en sortent
mieux notamment tous les échelons
locales les élus locaux les maires voilà
en général une meilleure image mais
c'est sûr que voilà c'est pas le genre
d'affaires qui va rehausser on va dire
la confiance à l'égard du enfin des
institutions en général c'est pas un
très bon signal dans cette période là
que de des 100 jours alors effectivement
je suis assez d'accord avec vous je
pense que le prix dans la pub avait
prévu là pour le 14 juillet de parler de
la France sereine
apaiser la France apaisée évidemment je
pense que ce terme-là
se ressortira sans doute pas de sa de ce
de sa prise de parole mais il a eu une
stratégie Emmanuel Macron de
surexposition
du chômage de la réindustrialisation des
choses comme ça mais on a l'impression
que ça touche pas leur quotidien et leur
préoccupations vraiment quotidiennes on
termine là-dessus merci beaucoup merci à
toutes les trois d'avoir participé à ce
premier débat bientôt sur sur public